well this is picking up steam as the day
grows on protests underway in several
cities as more states push to reopen
some in California are calling on the
governor to get the state back up and
running after he closed at beaches in
Orange County in Michigan protesters are
demanding an end to the stay at home
order we've got reporters in both states
that start on the west coast william la
jeunesse
Huntington Beach California William well
bill here in California you can meditate
tree climb golf get your Botox your pot
your alcohol the one thing you can't do
is go on that beach although it is being
widely ignored and not enforced still
that is the reason that people here are
protesting we're looking at maybe a
thousand people saying what they have a
see a patchwork of rules and selective
enforcement why well yesterday governor
Newsom his office said it planned to
close eight hundred and forty miles of
beach the entire coastline then in the
afternoon he reversed course closing
only one Orange County and some of those
beaches have raised alarm bells people
that are congregating there that weren't
practicing physical distancing we're
going to do a hard close in that part of
the state just in the Orange County area
it's clear example of unnecessary
government overreach his actions are
arbitrary and capricious and is an act
of retribution against Orange County
locals say Newson is punishing Warren
County based on a few press photos that
appear to show packed beaches last
weekend well now compare those to these
Newport Beach police say on Saturday
this is what it looked like peak hours 2
p.m. painting a very different picture
deputies and lifeguards say the vast
majority of visitors honored the
six-foot buffer and when asked they were
compliant to move locals say they are
neither ignorant of the rules more
reckless everything is shut down and you
leave to leave the water to the you know
the people that you know are enjoying it
healthy for us to be out in the water
and we keep our distance we want to be
safe but we must be free and we cannot
give up our freedom for saving now the
governor claims his policy is guided by
science and data however Orange County
has lower rates of infection
hospitalization and fatality the
neighboring LA and San Diego County and
studies in Japan and China so that your
19's more 19 times more likely to get
this virus indoors than out now the
cities of Huntington Beach as well as
Dana Point bill have filed a lawsuit to
be heard later this afternoon
challenging governor's closure of these
beaches but as you can see people are
out there they're surfing all day we've
seen them people are sitting and so
forth so they're going about their
business but as far as enforcement is
concerned right now they're not doing it
here in parts of Newport Beach they are
back to you well you've got the weather
is it going to get hot next week